[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about when you're mad oh
we match - OH
- it's not real friends for the hair bro
yeah we only find something guys
so Hawaii says we can come in Argus if
you take a test within the 72 hours and
then you'll and the corona test so if
you pass if you pass it you don't you
don't have to study but if you pass it
and you go there with the paper that
says you don't have a corona you don't
have to Florentine I'm supposed to be
there right now
what happened it sucks because my
friend's wedding was like some will see
right now and it sucks because you know
when you [ __ ] Google Calendar keeps
reminding you and I'm like I know I'm
not there how many things we suppose all
your lay I'll be there for like two
weeks two weeks yeah yeah did your
friends found out of the wedding - I've
never been to Hawaii all you never been
no it's the best man I can go
that's what you never been like pokey
yeah okay why did it's so much [ __ ]
better like beaches have you seen water
that's a balloon no syringes in the sand
that's true I was at Santa Monica beach
right and I was like riding bikes and I
was the whole time I was just hating on
it like this ain't Hawaii no but we
recently went for justice birthday and
that was the clearest I've seen la water
beach
there's no diapers in the wire there was
a dolphin we saw yeah I'm so magical and
then the water wasn't like dark green
swamp water
it was actually a light gray and so ah
we're getting there
have you guys heard about the the taboo
or the bad juju thing about Hawaii hmm I
didn't know about this ringing rocks and
seashells back oh no no bouquet no rocks
so someone told me recently like you're
not supposed to bring a significant
other to Hawaii unless you're already
engaged or else it'll you'll break up
real it came true for me
[Laughter]
why is why are you drinking cuz you got
Mary Ann bless you guys together for
like sixteen hundred years so but we
went there like twice three times four
five factors before yeah the spirits
don't it's real it's true love so like
the Hawaiian spirits could not yeah yeah
yeah so it's just you much so don't take
your your people's two ways so it's
50/50 kind of it and then they also say
don't take sand to the beach you know
I'm talking about
don't take sand to the beach yeah cuz
there's a lot of hot girls there so why
did I bring a girlfriend there don't
take sad to them you know why you know a
place to bring your date girlfriend will
do and you're like you supposed to meet
someone there you guys meet there and
son what about people that are proposed
there is like Hawaii did I did I did you
did it also yeah you did yeah I got
engaged in Hawaii and we did break up
not me you were engaged I think you
forgot I even know this story
they barrister in front of the whole
entire family and friends and it so she
couldn't say no cuz Tiff's back then
could never say no and then she was
always in too deep it shouldn't even
want to be with this dude but then like
she said yeah and in later she was like
actually I don't want to embarrass you
but I don't want to get married yeah
that is very nice embarrassing everybody
was there even one hour that you're like
I think I could do this Oh whole 30 days
was like oh the whole 30 days I was like
try not to throw up because no this is
gonna be a burst of my life I can't hold
in that spam musubi
no wait were you in Hawaii for a month
no no it was a month after we came back
from Hawaii which is like after we gotta
go guys
anyway we're gonna have to go but I like
I like it because it's not my life yeah
yeah yeah I know such as like a fairy
tale story like it was a that's how I
view things even in my life just like
even an hour ago that's good no cuz I
think you know like you know you know
how I think Dave Chappelle always says
is where he's like I'm half black half
comedian so I think like when you are a
comedian there's always this third
person so like let's see if I got hit by
a bus it's gonna be big alley for sure
but then almost immediately after I pull
myself out and I see myself getting
carried across I see true star [ __ ]
dying of a stranger's sense of humor
really I deal with it with humor to it
make sense
yeah like almost immediately I see how
stupid and how funny like whatever
tragedies yeah that's basically me after
my motorcycle accident I was just like
having a good time and laughing the
whole time and everybody who's like cuz
I grew up Buddhist I went to the book
I landed in the correct position but
yeah whenever bad stuff happens to me I
think if it's like in my head I'm like I
can't make the situation better already
might as well like laugh at it yeah
accepted the situation I think the
funniest moment would come
me and my friends we got stuck on the
Six Flags roller coaster but in position
like 45 degrees oh those like add a drop
not so about two or three carts were
turned and we were like the second or
third car somebody just froze there yeah
so froze there we were there for like at
least like 40 minutes and people were
like crying and stuff you know and then
climb down I would just be calling my
lawyer luck so it's very high up I can
point them bases yeah so Byron is there
and me and Byron were just kind of
laughing and making jokes the whole time
and then everybody else was like crying
and in tears but I like in mind I was
like there's nothing else we can do I
know you want to cry do this I don't
know I rather laugh to death
where's I would go live on Instagram I
know hey guys it's Jana coming at you
from the roller coaster ride
Oh at a theme park in Canada some guy
was live streaming being stuck on a ride
upside down no they were just like they
have their legs were hanging and they're
just sitting there turtle I got kids are
crying yeah so you could be like I might
either die right now or win a huge
lawsuit yeah well I only go one one or
two ways yeah I mean when we were stuck
there like I'm eventually like one of
those like teenage workers climbed up
the stairs to us and they were like okay
we're either gonna continue the ride or
you guys gonna climb off back here and
then walk down the stairs and I'm like I
don't like either of those two options
I'm like so do we know something's wrong
but we're gonna continue the route I
think it's like Goliath July oh that's
like the biggest drops oh my god I think
it was Alan thought that was Disneyland
you're at Magic Mountain yeah yeah yeah
do you trust so some people tell me
don't trust carnival rides and things
right yeah brother garden locals here's
our roller case that coaster in a
[ __ ] shoe box and moving it around
the country yeah but they taste it a lot
that's true of the news ever operating
is like you know that they're like
alcoholics that's true just kidding the
other theory to that is that those are
actually safer because they're
constantly working on them putting you
up and carrying it down putting it back
up so all this bolts and screws are done
freshly rags more worn they were worn
out
I'm just saying all the videos that I've
ever seen of rights failing we're
carnival rides true those local fairs oh
yeah but I'll still get on cuz it's
urine see you guys trust things outside
of America no absolutely not
yeah if you put me in a roller coaster
in China I'm gonna lose my mind
yeah I think Japan Germany the roller
coasters probably made by Mercedes I'm
okay yeah yeah yeah maybe Italy your
place does that make nice cars but you
know everyone says that's how your cars
falls apart like crazy yeah so it's
really fast but then it'll break
Japanese cars lasts forever but they
they are to close the door of a Japanese
I don't know about nowadays but it's
like this still feels ah yeah it's like
my first car was a 98 accord I would
ride that [ __ ] into Warren now at
100,000 miles dude
that [ __ ] was amazing there's still 98
of course on the street mm-hmm that are
probably doing half a million miles yeah
okay well I've been trying not to bring
this up but but you can't help it can't
help it this is all that I'm thinking
about are you thinking about loans I
have been because this off director is
sponsored by upstart during these
economically turbulent times everyone is
looking for a way to feel more
financially secure so if you're still
needlessly throwing money every month at
high interest credit card debt it's time
you checked out up start the
revolutionary online learning platform
that knows you're more than just a
credit score now is the time to find out
how low your up start rate can be to
help pay off high-interest credit card
debt
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your education and job
history in the form of a smarter rate
you don't need a degree or diploma to
apply though I'm sorry let you skip
going to the bank because it's
completely
online the off the loans from 1,000 to
$50,000 so you can consolidate your debt
into one easy fixed-rate payment upstart
makes it fast and simple to check your
rate since it's just a soft pool it
won't affect your credit score the hard
pool happens if you accept your rate and
proceed with your application the best
part if the loan is approved and
accepted most people get their funds the
very next business that's fact that's
really that's actually really fast
sugar-daddy
over over 400,000 people have used up
start to pay off credit cards to meet
their financial goals free yourself from
the burden of high interest credit card
debt and get back to using your money
your way with upstart okay guys so CY up
star has a four point nine out of five
rating on Trustpilot and hurry up to
upstart dot-com slash record to find out
how low your up start rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes
that's up Starcom slash record daddy up
start from now on that yes that's cool
well yeah okay well I'm glad you brought
that up
alright but you got another burning
topic everything yeah
so last night I kept tossing and turning
in bed and I kept waking up I kept
having these nightmares I know where you
go ahead yeah what you do Casey no yeah
well no I did not do this what ever sees
it not again hold on yes yes next in bed
yo okay this thing is really intense but
have you guys looked into the mole like
pizza gate stuff yes
what's pizza cake this is very confused
there's a lot of gates but I know that
this has to do something we'll touchy
kids yeah and make a gigantic richard
sheep kid yeah I'll just have to do it
pizza came in to the pizza place with
like his rifle yes that's after the fact
yeah oh my does this place call comet P
yes yes yeah okay and during the you
know those email leaks on with all the
politicians and things like whether
Hillary stuff yeah yeah
oh my email
yeah this was like like six years ago or
something like that it was it was a
while or 2016 I think it was during the
presidential election yeah I think
that's another thing but yeah so the
people were reading through all these
emails and then they saw some from some
politicians and a peeps in a pizza shop
and there was just these weird as like
it was like you want to go grab pizza
for an hour
it was weird emails yeah that was really
like yeah they're using it for two hours
you want cheese pizza for two hours and
no one no one talks about car dad's car
and so what that code is is it's it's
pedophile talk
it's a confirmed it's pretty close to
being confirmed because you know well
it's a it's still a conspiracy theory
but they're what pedophiles like secret
organizations used to identify like boy
lovers and whatever they have six
signals they have codes and in pedophile
talk like that exists on the dark web
and how they like communicate yeah
there's keywords and and codes and then
a lot of that was being used in the
email these pizzas stands for child porn
yeah
cheese pizza yeah yeah sorry hear
anybody talk about pizza I'm gonna beat
the [ __ ] up my view on pizza cuz I
absolutely [ __ ] love pizza yeah
cheese pizza though no no more cheese
pizza I don't like cheese pizza period I
like a bologna pizza adult porn
we ended up watching this like
documentary thing on YouTube it was like
out of the shadows or something and it
was just we saw this a couple weeks ago
and I was just think I was about
Hollywood that's about Hollywood and how
the media is all controlled by like one
group and
Thanks hello and all these things and
like and then Hillary and then and then
like drizzle drip and like oh my god so
many things miss Frizzle trip no okay so
okay so that was the file name on
Anthony Weiner's laptop and in yes the
perfect prison because he was like he
was talking about underage girl she
landed so his wife is part of Hillary's
campaign thing that's why was huge and
then like he what's a prison and the
wife like filed for divorce on these
things but apparently like the
conspiracy is that this file it like he
labeled it life insurance and that it's
[Laughter]
let me tell you it's just just no
warning this is gonna be intense okay so
apparently it's a video of Huma which is
his wife and Hillary that they were like
like taking this the face off of a
little girl like skinning her and then
putting it on their face so they could
be youthful or some [ __ ] and they were
saying that like the most hardened and
wise New York detectives and stuff like
they couldn't even handle the stuff that
was on his laptop they had to go and
throw up and that was just like so
intense I heard that oh they said that
that video was in that file is it
confirmed I don't know it's a theory I
just coming from it's just people aren't
like they I really don't know it's just
like this whole thing that people are
connecting the dots and it seems to be
like it kind of sounds like it makes
sense and a lot of shits coming out
these I'm not trying to like fully dive
in cuz I'm just like hold on let's be
low so it would mean Steve are talking
that this is why it sounds like bits and
pieces of the information it's a lot
right so you guys are barely breath the
beginning it's starting to put get your
foot feet wet in this whole thing so um
I think a lot of people have been have
been woken up to this stuff like about
ten years plus online massively before
that it was very very small right it all
started with this book called be
hold a pale white horse it was a former
CIA agent that wrote that book and and I
think they came out in the 70s or 80s or
whatever right and then so like the
conspiracy theory community was very
very small up until the point I think
site guys came out you guys remember
zeitgeist I've heard of that it was a
documentary made independently about
about Jewish no it's not about Jewish
people I know it sounds kind of like a
Jewish word but it's not but it's uh
it's kind of like um cuz that guy says
means like magazine or something like
that right the zeitgeist documentary is
basically how people in power use humans
as slaves just like we're all cattle to
them and there's a whole theory on like
how power has been centralized since the
dawn of time and it's been passed over
but whatever I think that's kind of like
one gateway another gateway was the JFK
assassination people that studied that
but then they all kind of go toward a
certain way even some people got into
ancient aliens like mm-hmm when they
watched a History Channel and then it
and that got him into a whole different
world we totally love it but in the
whole conspiracy world it's not all
connected but it's like a similar
community it's like people that are
thinking outside of the box thinking
outside the box you're not trusting the
system for face value or whatever and
then picking up on little clues and
you're trying to like make sense of it
and then like kind of like make it fit
into that narrative of the conspiracy or
whatever which is like okay yeah a new
one that I heard yesterday was was that
like with the whole quarantine and stuff
the cult corn the idea of the quarantine
is just to cover up for for a lot of
celebrities who are actually on house
arrest for some [ __ ] like like child
porn and all this stuff so saying that
like Ellen DeGeneres like people are are
they're picking up like screenshots or
photos or whatever of her being at home
and that there's like a little bulge
around her ankle so they're saying like
she looked under house arrest Wow Oprah
it's also tossed into the same
do you guys remember like when the whole
pizza gate thing first happens I
remember reporting it and I remember
thinking like this is ridiculous it's
like what like very true that's insane
how do you even get to that conclusion
but then after watching that documentary
we just saw I was like oh [ __ ] this all
makes sense
oh my god that's scary I think it's
because people don't read into it so
they'll see it for face value and be
like no [ __ ] way because I think most
people they don't want the reality to be
turned upside down because that's a
first sure way of getting into
depression so your mind creates ways to
going that's [ __ ] bogus homie let me
go back to playing [ __ ] Animal
Crossing yeah yeah but that's most
people don't right but I am the opposite
I'm like I want to know the truth cuz
what's the juicy [ __ ] I like up to me i
watch this [ __ ] like I'm watching [ __ ]
in real life like reality TV yeah that's
all like it's 90-day fiance let me
[ __ ] know about the [ __ ] dirt in
the world there's like three times
I remember just laying up at night now
would get kind of like upset that I
would never know easy things I want to
know yeah no that's the only reason why
I want to be a billionaire so I could
know the secrets and [ __ ] you know me
talking my stuff animals after watching
Toy Story like please just tell me and
then the animal like it moves a little
bit because it's kind of off balance
[Applause]
okay no for real though like I had this
vide the poohbear that would speak like
if you press the button or whatever the
stomach but then like when I'd be
staring at it I remember being like four
years old or five years old and just
being like promise I won't tell it
didn't did it go I hate you talking on
its own and I'm like that's confirmation
I know it oh my god yeah if that should
ever happen to me I'm throwing that
[ __ ] out the window I had a stuffed
raccoon and I would stare at it right
and I was like I'm like I couldn't smile
for blinked
so I'm staring at it cuz I want to catch
it blink but then my eyes would get
[ __ ] dry so I kind of like
hallucinate that just blinked you let me
stand outside like at a tree trying to
make a leaf move just [ __ ] stupid
kids are the best
[Music]
[Music]